so it just, like, works.
Look at how fast you're going.
Good job.
Hey, girls.
Hungry?
[ Both laugh ]
She's a professional.
♪♪
Someone's making
a dank Instagram story.
Yes, it's a story
about a grown
[Victorian English accent]
woman at the theater.
Theater, yes.
-It's starting.
-Damn it.
♪♪
Man: I'm so sick
of this attic!
Walk it off, Anne Frank!
Shh!
♪♪
[ Applause ]
Announcer: Please enjoy
a brief intermission.
Wow.
[ Voice breaking ] Wow.
[ Inhales sharply ]
They're gonna win
that Tony.
Oh, my God. Dude...
Does your eye stink?
[ Squelch ]
[ Sniffs ] Hoo!
Yeah, it stinks.
What's going --
Holy shit!
Ilana...
[ Sniffs ] It smells
like prosciutt.
You cannot go to
the DevaCurl shoot like this.
You got to go to a doctor
right away
and get this cleared up,
for the family honor!
Doctor? I don't have
a "doctor" "here."
Wait, you don't have
a doctor here?
No one in the city does.
That's why it's a cesspool.
All right, it's an emergency!
Go to the emergency room.
Go to St. Vincent's.
-It's condos.
-All right, so Cabrini!
-Also condos.
How 'bout that what's-his-name
doctor on Houston St.?
It's not condos,
but it's a Whole Foods.
[ Sighs ]
Again,
why do you love this city?
[ Coughs ]
You got to get an ambulance.
You -- You smell like
a dog's ass.
What'd you say?
A dog's ass.
Dog's ass --
That's it?
What?
Mwah!
Dude...
Okay, I know who can cure me.
I got this.
Oh, I hope so.
♪ Uh ♪
Oh, God.
...!
Come on.
♪♪
Hey, can you drive me downtown
and just weave
in and out of traffic
very fast?
Listen,
I'm not a pedicab driver.
I'm a real estate broker.
Read the sign.
[ Horn honks ]
Okay, then why do you
have a pedicab?
It's the fastest way
to get clients
to apartments
for multiple viewing.
You know, I think
I-I know you.
Are you a cop?
No.
Oh.
But you showed my friend and I
an apartment years ago,
a bunch of shitty apartment.
I mean, they were
all literal crime scenes.
Oh, yeah, crime scene homes
are my speciality.
You know, I got an ex
that works in the NYPD.
He hooks me up.
I just give him a hand job
once and a while.
Okay, since we have a history
can I please get a ride?
This is a modeling
emergency.
Look, I've been pedaling
my butt off all day.
I mean, look at my feet.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Wait a minute.
Flex that thigh.
Whoopsie!
I can see your short
and curlies.
[ Laughs ]
Let's go!
[ Grunts ]
[ Bell dings ]
Damn.
There you go.
You got it.
You should see your ass
from back here.
It's amazing.
It looks like a big heart.
Thank you, Pam --
Move! Scram!
Oh, let's go!
We have a medical
emergency!
Look out for the baby --
the baby!
Get out of the way!
[ Screams ]
[ Clattering ]
Well, well, well, Lesley.
[ Cellphone shutter clicking ]
One of these babies
could've been yours.
[ Smacks lips ] Shit.
Lighting is terrible
in here.
Gotta find another
light...source.
[ Indistinct talking
in distance ]
[ Groans ]
[ Music plays in distance ]
Yes! Daylight.
[ Grunts ]
Here we go.
Lesley's not gonna know
what hit her.
[ Cellphone shutter clicks ]
[ Screams ]
[ Groans, screams ]
[ Panting ]
[ Siren wails in distance ]
Shenanigans.
[ Sighs ]
[ Groans ]
Oh, sh--
Okay.
[ Cellphone vibrates ]
Oh, my God. Yes.
Ah! Yes!
Ow!
Hello? Somebody?
H-Hello?
Abbi?
It's Lesley.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Hey. Lesley.
[ Laughs ]
What's up...girl?
♪♪
[ Dogs barking in distance ]
Okay, I'm sorry.
I have to go before you.
I'm a model.
[ Sighs ]
The doctor's with a patient!
Yeah, I'm a model.
S-Stop!
Doctor --
Ohh! Sorry.
Ilana, I told you --
I can not spay-neuter a human,
and it is not reversible.
No, I-I Googled that --
you were right about it.
[ Inhales sharply ]
I'm here about this.
♪♪
Ugh. Okay.
[ Dog whines ]
That looks bad.
Have a seat.
Okay, good girl.
Good girl.
[ Dog whimpers ]
[Groaning ] Good --
Good girl!
Well, I actually wanted
to apologize to you.
For before.
[ Panting ]
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, did you see
my Instagram?
[ Chuckles ]
What?
Never mind.
Wh-Wh-What's up?
Look, the truth is,
I'm really set in my ways,
and maybe I'm self-sabotaging
this whole things
because I have a lot
of fun with you --
shenanigans and all.
I mean, who am I
to judge the way you live?
You know, you're --
you're figuring it out.
[ Horn honks in distance ]
[ Exhales sharply ] Wow.
Well, thanks --
I mean, thank you
for saying that.
I -- [ Sighs ]
You really hurt my feelings
this morning.
I know,
and I'm so sorry.
Do you think there's any way
that we can try this again?
You mean, like,
get back together?
Yes. I'd really like
to keep seeing you, Abbi.
I think you're great.
Well, I think
you're great, too.
I mean, [grunts]
what are you, uh...
What are you
doing tonight?
Well, I think
I may have a date
with my very adult,
very sexy artist girlfriend.
Yeah. I mean,
I'm down to...
hang.
Um, before we lock in
any logistics...
I've, u-um...
gotten myself in
a little bit of trouble.
[ Laughs ]
But, uh, I do need --
I do need you to call 9-1-1.
What?
And then you know what?
You pick dinner.
It's totally on you.
I'm cool with whatever.
Jesus Christ, Abbi.